jojo was geht hier ist euer marx und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute gibt es für euch zehn fakten über
mich eigentlich was aufnehmen was ein
bisschen origineller ist aber das hat
leider nicht funktioniert und ich dachte
mir in der letzten zeit sind so viele
neue zuschauer dazu gekommen dass es
vielleicht ganz interessant ist wenn ihr
wisst ihr was über mich erfahren und ich
würde sagen wir legen direkt los mit
fakt numero uno ich hasse streit als ich
glaube es gibt keinen menschen der
streit wirklich mag falls doch sehr
komisch bei mir geht das so weit dass
ich falls ich irgendwie streit habe das
total in den hintergrund dränge und
immer probiere um jeden preis einfach
diesem streit aus dem weg zu gehen auch
teilweise einfach so ein bisschen sache
nämlich rein fressen was keine so super
gute eigenschaft ist aber ja also bei
mir streit
ich habe ja immer so ein komisches
gefühl in mir und ich hasse dieses
gefühl und dann ist es bei mir so dass
ich eigentlich einfach immer probiere
mich aus zu sprechen bevor man in diese
nein du hast das gemacht du hast das
gemacht phase kommt sondern einfach
direkt zu sagen okay das ist sache das
war das problem und ja weil ich einfach
streit ziemlich heiße nummer zwei wenn
ich serien gucke die fähre dann lebe ich
da drin also es ist teilweise so dass
ich irgendeine serie entdecke die
schauer und dann gucke ich buchstäblich
10 bis 15 folgen am tag und ich lebe
dann da drin ist es einfach komisch für
mich dann aufzustehen aus meinem bett
oder vom sofa oder wo auch immer ich
dass die serie schaue und quasi weg zu
gehen und das normale leben zu leben wie
mein kopf ist dann einfach voll mit
diesen serien und ich bin einfach
vollkommen abwesend im echten leben weil
ich das den ganzen tag suchte und mich
sollen diese ganze geschichte
reinsteigern ja das mache ich gerne mal
du fragt nummer drei ich bin sneaker und
klamotten süchtig beziehungsweise ich
leg relativ viel wert darauf und das
schon seit eigentlich immer schon
seitdem ich zwölf bin oder so klick aber
auch immer so ein bisschen wert darauf
dass ich nicht so wie der mainstream
angezogen bin dass ich halt nicht immer
das an habe was gerade in ist also keine
longies oder so was seid ihr natürlich
sagt mir zu aber ich bin halt nicht so
ein
linde habe ja das fand ich persönlich
war auch ein ganz interessanter fakt und
wird dann beim sneaker video schreibt
die kommentare
das tue ich hier so wir kommen schon zu
fakt nummer vier und zwar einem geheimen
talent habe erst einmal einen menschen
getroffen er ist auch konnte und der
kann das auch nicht mit beiden ohren es
geht um die ohren sondern nur mit einem
und ja ich zeig euch mal
ich kann meine ohren abstellen und jetzt
kann ich sie zurückklappen verrücktere
also ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
sicher mögen wir so eine knorpel
fehlbildung dass ich wenig so hinter
schiebe einfach die ohren abstellen kann
und dann wieder zurück und ich kann das
sogar noch einen schritt weiter und
schaut einmal rein 23 supertalent oder
was sind eure supertalente schreibe es
in die kommentare und was wäre mein name
als superheld mit diesen ohren schreibt
auch dass in dem kommentar fakt nummer
fünf wenn ich an meinem handy oder einem
computer bin habe ich die langsamste
reaktionszeit der welt das geht so
ungefähr
ich werde so gerufen handy was also
wirklich fünf sekunden teilweise meine
freundin hat er schon mal gestoppt ist
nicht wirklich fünf sekunden wie ich
brauche bis ich dann reagieren ist es
richtig weiß nicht das ist irgendwie so
ein komischer eigenschaft von ja so wenn
wir schon bei freunden sind dann fakt
nummer sechs ich führe eine
fernbeziehung und zwar über 230 km ich
wohne in der nähe von frankfurt meine
freundin der nähe von köln bis ein
relativ großer entfernen aber ich bin ja
sowieso gerne in köln und von daher ist
das eigentlich ganz cool und absolut die
sache wert so fakt nummer acht ich bin
absoluter harry potter nerd ich habe die
bücher ungefähr 5 mal gelesen alle dabei
bin ich sonst gar nicht so die über
leseratte also harry potter ist krass
das habe ich so häufig gelesen und habe
die firma mindestens genauso oft
geschaut also es ist wirklich vollgas
ich kann die sätze immer mitsprechen
wenn ich den film mit freunden schauer
und
ich weiß es nicht das ist einfach
magisch und ich freue mich auch schon
krass auf den neuen film wir jetzt raus
kontakt nur 9
ich bin kein zocker main kanal heißt
zwar krankhafter was von minecraft kommt
aber es gibt kein spiel was ich wirklich
suchte so league of legends oder so
zocken leute ja richtig lange richtig
freut mich und ich zog ab und anderen
runde minecraft vorwiegend für aufnahmen
und wenn überhaupt andernfalls noch ein
zweimal im monat oder so fifa
normalerweise wenn ich halt mit kumpels
oder meinem bruder spiele also kein
zocker obwohl ich in gaming kanal habe
so zu guter letzt nummer 10 ich habe in
der schule ziemlich viel mist gebaut
früher es gab mal ein jahr in dem hab
ich sechs hinweise und drei verweise
bekommen weil ich echt wie gesagt
relativ viel mist gemacht habe ich habe
die hausaufgaben nicht gemacht scheiße
gebaut so eine kurze geschichte ich
hatte latein bei einer neuen lehrerin
und ich und mein bester freund damals
haben halt zu sagen ziemlich viel
quatsch gemacht immer mist gebaut und
dann haben wir uns überlegt kay west was
wäre lustig so eine neue lehrerin erster
eindruck ist wichtig wie wäre es wenn
ich sage ich bin du und du sagst ich bin
ich das haben wir also gemacht ich habe
gesagt ich heiß fabi und das haben wir
irgendwie monat lang durchgezogen bis
dann fabi abgefragt werden sollte habe
habe ich gespielt in dem moment und dann
wurde er abgefragt also ich habe sechs
bekommen und dann hab ich's aufgedeckt
und da hat die lehrerin sich schon
gedacht okay das sind zwei vollidioten
und ja ab diesem zeitpunkt hatte ich
ziemlich verpackt und überhaupt war ich
da in der schule in diesem jahr nicht
besonders gut drauf also mit noten offen
mit mitschülern und so weiß ich weil
jugendliche
hofmann ja leute das war's aber vom
heutigen video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen
falls ist das getan hat lasst doch mal
ein like oder ein abo da und dann will
ich sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten
mal wieder
bis dahin macht es gut und schau